there's one there's potentially one
argument for Biden chaos vote G just
because like you want to see a deranged
old senile man press the nuke button I
guess but he wouldn't it wouldn't be by
yeah no I don't know man he's gonna be
in it like I guess maybe he like they
wheelchair him into a meeting with like
the Ayatollah in Iran and he's like and
they're like that's great grandpa you
heard me you hurt you heard him say
attack right I heard him say attack
that's not yeah no he said attack all
right attack it's gonna they're gonna
wheelchair him into the room and then
whoever the VP is will walk up and be
like we're now they'll lean up out of
the door to the reporters we're now
getting ready for negotiations and then
the journalist start writing things down
and then they start wheeling Joe Biden
out of the room and they just Pete they
put him by the window and he's like
slumped over sleeping with like the Sun
beam on him I guess he's got a blanket
on his lap you know the second Lord of
the Rings film the the land of the
horses or whatever land of the horses
and you got the king that's all white
and frail yeah and the guy whispering in
his ear like you don't he doesn't belong
here
that's the VP and there's Biden yeah
that was like Cheney and Bush so you
know what man this even it's even worse
here here one of the one of the bigger
problems that Democrats have I think is
that they're trying to go for the
resentment vote that the who hates Trump
right right right but by doing so
they're generating an inverse reaction
sure because people like me I am so sick
and tired of the lies same here
I want to see that like in 2016 check it
out
your see that video of woman falling to
our knees and screaming yes you showed
it to me yeah yeah it's a funny viral
meme it is pretty good I know this woman
is I mean or no disrespect I don't care
I see that a lot now I I felt the only
thing I felt when I saw this stuff back
in 2016 was I left I'm like man these
people sure are crazy but now they've
actually got me emotionally invested in
wanting to wanting the schadenfreude is
it schadenfreude he pronounces shatan
Frodo yeah they've actually got me such
so emotionally invested in being sick
and tired of their lives now if I saw a
video like that it'd make me feel good
like like catharsis you know we've
endured man
when Russia Gate happened I was like
well you know this may happen we should
entertain these these these
investigations see what happens and then
it turned out it was bunk and I'm like
well now that we've all determined it's
fake we can all move on and they didn't
yeah
then we got Ukraine gate now I was like
are you seriously doing this again then
they tried to impeach him and I was like
oh no now I'm like I long for the day
when you get to feel some kind of come
up and for all that you have put us
through
you think it'll eyes yeah I think
Trump's gonna win I think so did one
reason Donald Trump under him for the
first you know several years the economy
was on fire best numbers of our lives
says Jim Cramer of CNBC then the
pandemic hits in the economy has fallen
into the gutter who is better equipped
and who has proven they can improve the
economy Joe Biden or Trump well what
about this whole thing that it was it
was Obama that set up the economy to do
so well under Trump nope
Trump made wait I don't I don't know if
this is the truth or not but that's what
Obama people are arguing what what did
Obama say like 4% would be impossible
yeah I dream he doesn't have a magic
wand and then oh look at that
and then Obama was like well that was
actually me and then the economy tanked
it knows like Obama said that he said
you there's no magic wand you can't hit
those numbers and then jump hit the
numbers yeah okay so I love it how
whenever when when economy's bad they're
like well that's the current president's
fault I mean economy's good they're like
well you realize there's a delay effect
from the previous president that's not
true look Donald Trump had tariffs
crushed the TPP he made a ton of
dramatic changes the craziest thing to
me it was what Michael Moore said that
Trump walked into that auto execs and
told him straight up I'm gonna put a 30%
tax on your cars no one will hurt by him
again and Michael Moore said this and he
was like this sent a message to people
in Michigan like Trump's actually
standing up for you it's the weirdest
thing why did Michael Moore if to sell
his soul not like he was a great person
to begin with but that that monologue he
had back in 2016 the biggest f you yeah
he's right so you you get someone like
that with Trump who has proven the
economy worked under him yeah really
well man seems like it yeah before the
pandemic I had spoken with several
people who said things like I have never
made more money in my life yeah you when
I best years of my first
here you you ordered Domino's randomly
right yeah and on top of the Domino's
box was like we're hiring managers you
know six figures and Lobell Domino's six
figure job like what Taco Bell announced
managers would get hundred K a year
that's insane because the competition
was so fierce yeah cuz unemployment was
so low so what you can Chris like I said
a million times there's there's tons of
things you can call them out for me I
usually come out in foreign policy
yeah when it comes to what the American
people want in November I think they're
gonna be looking at sleepy creepy Joe
yeah and he unless they get rid of him
maybe they will and Donald Trump all has
to do is say for the first three years
of my first term the economy was the
best we'd ever seen yep due to an
unforeseen crisis the pandemic mm-hmm
the economy took a hit I will make this
economy better than ever
just like I did the first time and
people gonna say I believe him you know
Matt why me why would I trust you Oh
Biden that dudes gonna fall asleep yeah
seriously yeah I do you know what he
wants by the way Tim I came up with it
Joe Biden wants to retire yeah he wants
a rocking chair and I don't blame him
how long has he been in politics since
like 200 BC 1778 I think should retire
man I feel I feel like yeah it is sad
it's abuse it's yeah it's you know you
know what it is it's like remember what
we talked about the other day like when
Obama said you don't have to do this Joe
yeah it was Joe Biden he's like you know
he people just hand on Obama's shoulder
and he's like I'll be the sacrifice for
the chrony establishment you can count
on me Joe wake up oh oh yeah they're
throwing the wolves there like this you
know it's it really does feel like in
2016 the Republican establishment tried
their hardest to stop Trump they
couldn't do it they didn't cheat though
the Democrats cheated Bernie and Bernie
wasn't strong enough to push back like
the easiest example of this is remember
when and I don't know if you watch the
debates do you see one ender yeah and
rangs mic was turned off no you saw that
right yeah America and Marianne
Williamson so in the Democrat debates
there's a scene that there's one point
where people were talking and then you
see Andrew yang start talking but you
can't hear anything he like raised his
hand you see his mouth move
sound comes out do you remember that
yeah yeah they turned his mic off do you
have any idea what Donald Trump would
have done if his mic was awful it that
he'd go like this he'd walk over to the
Bell Mike excuse me no my microphone
excuse me
no excuse me I'm talking now you need to
fix my microphone you would you would
totally I absolutely agree and that's
why he will well well played sir excuse
me when all-in totally you wouldn't lean
over and grab someone's mic and go
excuse me I'm trying to talk here
microphone needs to be turned back on
yep what did Andrew yang do he's polite
probably yeah yeah and I got I got mad
respect for young I like to do I think
is very smart but when it comes to
cutthroat politics of that level yeah
you gotta you gotta have more that Trump
in you yeah yeah yeah Joe Biden there's
nothing higher it's like he's just a
withered husk put him in a wheelchair
and we'll you know it's like what CNN
wanted to have a debate where he sat
down yes yeah it's gonna be hilarious
watching them they put it they put him
in a wheelchair Trump's gonna eat him
apart
yeah part of me really wants to watch
Park
pardon me really does since I cannot
wait to watch I kind of seriously I
don't care
I can't wait no man it's gonna be good
it's gonna be good
I think they're taking bets on Cuomo
coming in yeah I saw there I think so
Jacobin which is the socialist magazine
what hasn't chosen I don't like it I
don't like the way that they're gonna
try to do this if they try to do it who
knows it might be too late it's too but
um Jacobin the socialist magazine wrote
that you know rumors are circulating
they're gonna pull him out good maybe
and that's that's why I think maybe
they're not really admitting it about
Joe Biden scandals hmm maybe what
they're really doing is him doing air
quotes admitting it so that they can be
alike you guys are right we're gonna
have to get rid of them or they're just
biding time yeah they're trying to like
extend it until it's too late oh by the
way boom here's a new candidate that's
why I don't think they're gonna get I
don't know what they're gonna do it's it
is bedlam you don't it is it's it's
though it's the last bit of the ship is
still above the water as it sinks and
there's like seven establish
people crowded in the top trying to
figure out what to do to save their
chrony establishment there as soon as
Biden said I'm gonna pick a woman as a
VP the Hillary documentary came out it
was like boom Hillary every time I would
turn on anything it was like Hillary's
face I'm like why am I seeing her face
everywhere this happened then all of a
sudden now she's doing town hall
meetings with him
oh don't worry Joe you can go ahead and
yell leap I got this and I'm gonna be
talking it's like what is going on here
like it stopped she didn't go in and I
cave I thought I said it as a joke I
said as a joke I got I got a question
can I take out life insurance policies
on people I don't know like Joe Biden
well if he picks Hillary as a VP yep
what is the biggest policy you offer I
think it's gonna happen I'm gonna be
sitting in the insurance like office
yeah and I'm gonna ask can I can I get
an insurance policy on someone I don't
know and there'd be like well I guess so
who's your choice what you heard
recently that he'll that Hillary was the
VP choice for Biden yes I would like to
know that no no way we're not doing that
the guy's gonna be like oh I'm not
taking bets
this is the 20th time someone has come
up with this idea yeah yeah he's gonna
he's gonna be like we can certainly
arrange that just signing that ID line
and I'll go that's not weird to you know
about 50 other people just signed the
same policy or Leo yesterday it's like
it's like when a hundred thousand people
win the same lottery they all get like a
dollar instead of dollars everybody gets
radar sure you could take out this
policy I mean all these other people did
it so you get a little bit the CEO of
the insurance company takes out an
insurance policy on Biden with another
company for his company because he's
like covered yeah man November is gonna
be fun fun so yeah I hope it ends up
being fun and not something worse I'm
choosing to well how would you fund how
would you feel if Biden won I mean I
don't know yeah I I don't know I'd laugh
I'd laugh the same as I laughter I would
I would be more nervous about our
in our country than I would if Trump won
again you know you know in 2016 I felt
like Hillary was way worse than Trump
okay
but not enough to motivate me to want to
support Trump at all okay now
Joe Biden is the same thing as Hillary
like that was the same administration
and now you take you take the the the
evil that is Hillary Clinton mm-hmm and
combine it with senility now I'm
freaking out yeah cuz like could you
imagine like you look at Witch of the
West but she's like mentally deranged
forgetting where she put her broom but
all power like as powerful as like the
flying monkeys going around but she
can't think straight so she's just like
smashing things and like throwing things
at people you'd be like that's at least
the Wicked Witch has a plan I guess sure
so but but i but i didn't want her to
win either now Joe Biden really scares
me because he's like he embodies all of
that plus he's lost his mind
but you know is that fair he's not gonna
he's not gonna be president even if he
wins I love the mean that's going around
it's a kim jeong-hoon but his face is
Hillary's face it's frightening but
amazing it's really good
total side note but just as a side note
there's a mean we have to look at
there's a mean it's pretty good but I
guess I kind of just I was we were
listening to to a Rogan podcast on the
way to Rogan and it was I think Owen
Smith and he mentioned that the Biden
vote will probably be people who want
that feeling back of what life was like
during the Obama years oh okay what
feeling was that you asked me earlier
like what would Biden bring you know and
then I think back to like what was he
saying what do I remember him saying
whenever he spoke half of the time I all
I could hear was Obama well back when me
and Obama were together and back back
mama mama-mama it's like this is what
about now yeah but that's that's that's
the problem of his policies bright eyes
if you actually look at his track record
the left hates his policies hmm it's
like tell me you Biden when you locked
up those kids in cages and built the
cages in the first place Bob dog well I
mean they called Obama the DePorter in
chief yeah that's right like I'd be Joe
Biden has that legacy behind
and that's I think my favorite one of my
favorite articles was from I think CNN
or wasn't Washington Post maybe can't
member who okay they said when did
Barack Obama become a Republican CNN and
then Washington Post wrote Barack Obama
comma the conservative and I'm like wow
I don't know that makes me moderate I
guess in rock obama is the conservative
now but i guess it's because and i've
long maintained this donald trump ran as
a moderate and so because they tried
using the far-right smear they shove
themselves into so into the far left
corner yeah cuz if trump is far right i
don't know where else do you go after
that yeah it's like they go to push but
they're pushing against a wall just
moving themselves right yeah yeah well
where it was
what is trump way do you know what
you're like 260 60 something like
seriously dude but he's like six
felonies would fires right pretty heavy
yeah yes yeah he's obese his doctor said
like oh really yeah i think he's on my
blood medicine or something part
medicine I've heard he's on uppers to is
that true
uppers yeah I don't know yeah he tastes
like some kind of stimulant I don't
think he takes any stimulants um I think
that he's just high-energy that I don't
know I heard that though I heard that
I'm not saying it's true but I did heard
that he takes like some kind of like
upper oh sorry Pepsi no no look it up it
could just be another smear and there's
one of the other big problems like if
you came out right now and told me that
Donald Trump shot a guy in Fifth Avenue
I'd be like I don't believe you because
the press is always lying yeah I'd be
like you know so when he did that whole
injecting bleach thing yeah I saw it and
I was like whoa and then I immediately
did a segment where I was like yeah I
was a stupid thing to say and then I did
some more digging and I was like okay I
mean he kind of was but what actually is
being overblown in a lot of different
ways and then a bunch of bull said to me
like I can't believe you fell for this
and I was like you're right how did I
fall for this yeah how did i of all
people fall for this you of all people
to seriously they're lying all the time
I know they're lying all the time yeah I
don't mean literally all the time I know
now you're gonna find some like weird
activists grouping like Tim Poole is a
conspiracy there's think the media only
lies ever no I used all of their so I
use mainstream sources all the time I
should have I have to fact-check them
constantly because it's kind of like in
mainstream media you have a bunch of
journalists that are LAN
they're the equivalent of landmines inka
out of the hundred journalists they have
how many of them are activists secretly
working to push a political agenda a lot
yeah not most though I wouldn't I
wouldn't bet most cuz what people don't
realize is that a lot of the columnist
for like the New York Times who write
these things don't actually work there
it's like they have a column where
they've a contract to write once a month
or something a lot of the journalists
write really boring things you never
read because it'll be like a sentence
where it'll be like you know today the
stocks rebounded blah blah blah in fact
there's a lot of robots to do that so
there are a lot of regular journalists
you'll never hear their names but most
of the people we see when we're talking
about journalists are like Twitter
activists and so we see this hyper
concentration and so then when I'm
navigating the news it's like walking in
a minefield
you've got like I'll step on a mine and
I'll go ha and then have to crouch down
and there's the activist journalist and
defuse it and then you walk and like for
the most part you walk through this
field there's real news all over the
place mm-hmm but then those landmines
are there and so the average person
reads fake news it's blown away yeah
like the new The Daily News in New York
wrote calls to poison control spike
after Donald Trump says to ingest bleach
or whatever mm-hmm fake news totally
totally fake they did it it's a false
correlation the spike in phone calls was
happening months before Trump ever said
anything of course
it was because people were buying
disinfectant in general having it around
more yeah yeah so then they come they do
this so I could write something like you
know Tim pools house burns down after
atom by you know atom orders spicy wings
from a vegan restaurant super spicy and
then people like the goal is to make
them assume you had something to do with
my house burning down when in reality
it's like those are two totally separate
separate events how do they know yeah
well if I said something like you know
House / Tim Fools house burns down after
Ian starts a bonfire then you assume the
bonfire did it but I never said that I
had it was after now I really want wings
is that weird thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you